we're now only about a month away from
Apple's annual WWDC event where they're
going to be revealing a bunch of new
hardware and software products including
iOS 17 so in this video I'm going to
give you an entire rundown of all of the
leaks and rumors surrounding what we
should be getting in terms of new
features with iOS 17 including some that
will be exclusive to the iPhone 15 Pro
Models later this year so let's jump
right into it now the major headlines
actually came from Mark grimmon from
Bloomberg back in March basically saying
that iOS 17 would provide several of the
most requested features basically the
rundown is that Apple was thinking of
making iOS 17 more of a regular kind of
tune-up upgrade but they thought they
had to add in a lot of features to make
people very satisfied sort of like what
they did with the recent 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pro redesign where they made it
a lot more like the previous map MacBook
Pro and brought back a lot of Highly
requested features like the max save
connector and the SD card slot so
basically we already know that iOS 17 is
intended to make people very happy with
features that have been requested for
years now one of those is actually the
control center which has stayed the same
for many many years in fact from IOS 11
that was released in 2017 apparently
there's going to be major changes
including a new redesign of how it's
going to work but this anonymous source
didn't really get into the details of
everything that's changing now we also
got a huge thread of exclusive leaks and
changes for iOS 17 from analyst 941 on
Twitter now if you think it's just some
weird random source that nobody cares
about he actually did give us some
confirmed leaks in the past for example
he was the first one that confirmed that
there would be a single pill cut out in
the software on the iPhone 14 teen Pro
rather than the original shape that
looked like an eye so he did say that
was coming and he also leaked the basics
of the dynamic Island about a week
before the launch including the return
of battery percentage so he got all of
that right so I think we can trust this
Source he confirmed that all iPhones
with an a11 bionic or higher will be
supported including the iPhone 10. he
also said that we're gonna get
performance efficiency stability and
long-term support for older devices as
one of the main features which is kind
of like a tune-up upgrade which is nice
to see because usually it seems like
those older devices get slower but apple
is working on improving it he also
mentioned the control center changes
with differences in the UI and even
further customization which is actually
really nice he also mentioned the
dynamic Island will do a lot more than
before with apple really pushing the
marketing to sell more of the iPhone 15
lineup because the regular iPhone 15 and
15 Max will be getting the dynamic
Island so a lot of the regular consumers
who go for the regular iPhone 15 will
have that so Apple really has to push
the marketing number six there's more
always on display settings more Focus
mode filters notification changes and
additional options in the settings
custom accessibility settings will give
total control over the UI and layout for
older persons or younger children active
widgets are in testing which a lot of
people have asked for active widgets and
widget upgrades so that is going to be
awesome including one tap button sliders
and more basically making widgets
finally more useful there is car key and
carplay improvements Health app UI
changes including like a redesign camera
app changes which I'll actually get into
later on in this video improved search
and Spotlight in an absolute Behemoth of
AR kit apis and Frameworks which that is
going to be used mainly alongside the
new VR headset this one right here is
one I'm actually very excited about
because right now we have the dynamic
Island but for some reason the whole
Siri UI and logo is at the bottom of the
display forcing you to look down it's
very annoying I wish they had it at the
top and it looks like apple is
considering moving it into the dynamic
Island on newer iPhones running iOS 17
that is very exciting I really hope they
do that they build in just like they did
with face ID Wall Street Journal also
posted this exclusive leak saying that
apple is going to be releasing an iPhone
journaling app for logging daily
activities basically giving your own
personal journal to basically write and
type in which is actually really cool
apparently the app is codenamed Jurassic
and it's designed to help users keep
track of their daily lives but the weird
thing is that they're saying the app is
going to analyze the user's Behavior to
determine what a typical date is like
that is kind of weird because they're
looking into what you're writing into
your Journal so I'm not sure about that
feature if it actually is coming mark
German also said that iOS 17 is getting
wallet in find my improvements with a
redesigned apparently analyst 941 also
created a mock-up showing what is going
to look like and you can see it right
here with some new features as you can
see it has this sort of layout with all
of your cards kind of stacked onto each
other there's kind of a different design
to everything right here so that is
going to be another update here's
another one we had a leak from weibo
basically saying that iOS 17 is going to
have a new lock screen with
customizations Apple music and app
Library features basically saying that
we're getting lock screen font size
options so now instead of just changing
the font you can change the size which
is really cool because some of them are
quite large there's going to be a button
to share custom lock screen designs with
other iPhone users Apple music lyrics
can be viewed on the lock screen that is
a major one for me because right now you
can't see lyrics unless the app is open
and on so that is a really cool change
I'm hoping they definitely bring that
Apple music design changes with a
simplified interface app Library folders
can be manually renamed control center
design changes which we already know and
the flashlight brightness slider can be
freely adjusted just like volume so you
have perfect fine tuning of the
brightness now on top of that analyst
941 also showed a new grid view for
wallpapers in iOS 17 so basically
instead of having to swipe through your
custom lock screen wallpaper setups you
actually have this grid view if you like
to create a ton of them which makes it a
lot easier to delete them and choose the
right one so that's really cool here's
another one from our grooming apparently
iOS 17 is going to include a mood
tracker occur which is very interesting
apparently it's going to use kind of
your sensors and all of your health app
data to see how your mood is even better
it's going to have an AI based Health
coaching service which I guess is
co-named quartz and it's going to be an
AI based service which will encourage
users to exercise improve their eating
habits and take steps to improve their
sleep that's pretty unique the only
downside is that he did warn that it
could potentially be canceled or
postponed so don't rely on this to come
this year and right here we actually
have the Apple Hub on Twitter create
some kind of imagery or mock-up of how
these could look like for example here
on the left you can see the text size
adjustment slider right here you can see
the share wallpaper section here kind of
like what it could look like here's the
lyrics on screen here's the lock screen
lyrics for Apple music that looks
amazing and the music app being a little
bit more redesigned and simple now this
right here is huge from nine to five Mac
apparently iOS 17 is gonna come with
side loading apps but it's not coming to
the US yes apparently it's only coming
to the EU where it is going to be
required by law and the way Apple's
gonna do this is with a feature that 95
Mac exclusively reported on apparently
iOS 16 already has a new hidden system
that can restrict specific features
based on the user's location and
apparently the way this is going to work
is that if you have an iPhone and then
you travel to the EU it's gonna see
where you're at using a new system
internally called country D which was
silently added with iOS 16.2 and it's
going to enable side loading however if
you buy an EU iPhone and bring it into
the US it's not going to work so it's
going to be a very smart system but it
sucks to see apple is locking it down so
much but of course they're protecting
their profits here is an interesting
image from basic apple guy showing
landscape home screen mode which I don't
know if it's actually coming it used to
be on the older iPhones like the iPhone
8 plus but it disappeared this is one
way it could potentially look but I'm
not sure if it's actually coming or not
here's another one from analyst 941
apparently apple is really going to be
trying to push people to use FaceTime
with some major refinements coming this
year making it a lot better and now we
get into the very interesting leaks some
of which are going to be exclusive to
the iPhone 15 Pro now he did say the
pros are gonna have Thunderbolt 3 which
is interesting because other leakers
said it's going to be USB 3.0 but he
says it's going to be Thunderbolt 3 for
sure and he did say there's going to be
special Thunderbolt 4 features in iOS 17
but they're not going to see the light
of day until the iPhone 15 Pro gets
released because it's reserved for them
for example a new cinematography
recording feature that will allow live
4K Thunderbolt outputs to monitors while
recording yes just like a professional
camera has right now where you could
grab a cable connect it to a portable
monitor and get a huge live feed as
you're recording you're going to be able
to do that with an iPhone 15 Pro to
actually see the live 4k camera footage
that is a cool cool feature and even
better he says that apple is heavily
invested into video recording this year
rather than Stills with a focus on
recording output features like importing
to workstations so with Thunderbolt 3
that transfer speed is going to be
absolutely mind-blowing going to a
workstation Commuter so you can edit
much quicker than you can with the
regular lightning Port iPhones right
right now and what if you could even
connect an SSD and direct record onto
that instead of the internal storage
that would be really cool that something
that Max suggested and now we have info
on the action button which is coming to
the iPhone 15 Pro even though we're not
getting the solid state volume buttons
we have some information on this
apparently the volume up plus power
button will no longer be used to power
off the device or force restart it the
sequence remains but it's going to go
over to the action button plus power
button which I think makes a lot more
sense furthermore within the camera app
the action button will now take a photo
instead of using the volume button which
is very cool light pressing it will
apparently autofocus the camera which is
really really sweet just like a real
digital camera these days hard press
takes a photo and hard long press will
capture and record video so it is going
to be real action but and now finally to
finish it off we have this cool little
Final Cut iOS icon and that might not
make sense until you look at another
leak from analyst 941 who says Final Cut
Pro is coming to iPad OS in 2024 so
that's next year going into a new 14.1
inch iPad model with dual 6K external
display support so basically that hints
that maybe Final Cut could even be
coming to iOS in the future but
definitely not this year so with all
that said let me know what you think
about these iOS 17 leaks in the comment
section below thanks for watching click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and we'll see you
in the next video
foreign